avec le samu complètement débordés les
pompiers prennent la relève et des
interventions liées aux coronavirus qui
se multiplient pour les 250 mais le
pompier du pays
et même si la pandémie est la priorité
les hommes du feu doivent aussi être sur
les autres fronts comme le rappelle à
notre micro algues et briller le plus
porte parole des pompiers de paris
les opérations des pompiers de paris
consiste en grande partie au quotidien
1500 fois par jour on part sur
intervention pour 80% de ses
interventions il concerne le secours à
personnes et 400 d'entre elles chaque
jour le kobe de 19 mai pour autant
l'activité normale continue notre
mission exclusive c'est d'éteindre des
feux
quatorze mille feux par an sur paris et
la petite couronne
il faut être prêt à le faire donc il
nous faut regarder un certain nombre de
moyens de ressources humaines pour
pouvoir prendre en compte ces sinistres
qui sont notre métier personne ne fera
de place mais pour autant notre mission
est aussi en appui de concourir à sel
mène avec brio les soignants les
médecins on a nos propres médecins
on a nos propres infirmiers on a nos
propres secouriste ces gens là sont
polyvalents ils interviennent pour le
coc vie de 19
aujourd'hui c'est l'actualité mais
peut-être ce soir pour un grand feu pour
un accident important